[Music]
morning everybody seven o'clock here in
the uk you're very welcome to spend your
breakfast with us
right here at sky news the lifting of
restrictions in
england might have encouraged some of us
to get our dancing shoes on but the
fallout might be a bit of a buzz kill
for some after the
news that people will have to prove
they've had two jabs
to enter some large crowded venues we'll
be asking the small business minister
paul scully
what exactly that means in just a few
moments plus
a fresh attack on the pm from his former
chief advisor dominic cummings
[Music]
dragstar dear coffee is on the program
to talk about the nightclub revival
and we'll also uh be speaking to a dutch
epidemiologist about what happened
in the netherlands when clubs reopened
there
it wasn't good in addition
what do you think about our shorts
paralympic champion who was told her
sprinting briefs
were too brief we'll hear from olivia
breen
at a quarter tonight it's tuesday the
20th
of july
[Music]
fallout on the dance floor nightclub and
theatre bosses
anger and sadness at the government's
plans for vaccine passports to gain
entry
i'm determined to try and keep it going
for as long as we can
i mean but um there does come a point
where we can't
just literally i mean we're talking
about hundreds of people who are
employed
don't cross the pond a warning from u.s
officials to american citizens
not to travel to the uk due to rising
coronavirus
cases plus could spain be on the way to
amber plus
record crossing we're live on the coast
as more than
430 migrants make the journey across the
english channel
the highest figure ever for one day
a premier league star has been arrested
on suspicion
of child sex offenses
and we're live in japan as the tokyo
olympics counts down to the opening
ceremony
and counts up the number of covet
infections
telling his story prince harry reveals
he's planning a memoir
of his life what will it reveal
and many places are now in a heat wave
across the uk
and for the first time ever the met
office have now
issued an extreme amber heat warning
which is valid until the end of thursday
i'll have the details for you
morning everybody it was a day of
lifting restrictions
but as the day drew to a close a
surprise announcement to bring
some new ones a along nightclub industry
bosses
say the plan to make people prove
they've had two kobe jabs to enter
large crowded venues from the end of
september
is a shambles theater boss andrew lloyd
webber who's been forced to cancel the
opening nights of his musical cinderella
after staff self-isolation pings was
even moved to tears molina veseladovich
reports now and
just to let you know that her report
does contain flashing images
the freedom to go dancing will soon come
with strings attached
proof you've had two jobs from september
but then all over 18s will be offered
both vaccines
what i don't get is why is it not the
same rule for what
for everyone the virus spreads whether
it be in a restaurant
a bar a sports event a theater show
so why is it why is it not the same
rules across the board
but he's pinpointing nightclubs and i
just don't get it
among those heading for the dance floor
mixed views on having conditions imposed
i won't be taking a jab and that's going
to affect me from going to enjoy myself
and i've already been locked up in my
house for so long and then you want to
lock me up again because
i don't want to take the chat and i
think we also don't know the rest of the
vaccine necessarily so i get why people
expect this if i've had both
but i feel like people should have a
personal choice no no problem whatsoever
it's
almost similar to showing your id to get
into a club if you're 18 or above of
course i'm happy to get my second job as
well yeah 100 like we've all had our
first jobs we've been queueing for ages
to get one
there are concerns that vaccine take up
among young people
is slowing 35 percent of those under 30
haven't even had a single dose yet
but not everyone agrees that vaccine
passports for nightclubs
are the right incentive even with
restrictions lifting the nighttime
industry
continues to suffer andrew lloyd webber
cancelled the opening of his new london
production of cinderella
because one positive case sent cast and
crew into isolation
i mean there comes a time i suppose
where we simply won't be able to go on
there does come a time um i mean we
we we really are are pretty much at that
point now
um i'm determined to try and keep it
going for as long as we can i mean
but um there does come a point where we
can't just literally i mean
we're talking about hundreds of people
who are employed and
not just uh directly but indirectly
well we as i said we have to ask our
beloved prime minister
milanov sky news
small business minister paul scully
joining us now hello to you mr scully
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning vaccine passports from
september nightclubs we're told on other
crowded venues
uh give me more examples
uh well it's a anything that's where
large people get large numbers of people
come together that uh
we we're encouraging to use uh a
certification
uh showing that we want people to do it
voluntarily if it's um
you know big comings together because we
want to stop the spread of the uh
of the the case numbers going up uh
immediately
but uh we will be looking at this and
working out how to operate
operationalize it making sure that
people can use it smoothly
but the message is at the moment is also
is
get your vaccination 85 of adults have
had their first dose
and we're really keen to have that first
that the last 15
of people vaccinated as well so that we
can really come to the end
of of this of this transmission of the
disease yeah my question was give me
more examples sir of
of uh areas where you will have to have
a vaccine passport
for example will you need to have it to
go to a crowded pub
uh no we're not saying crowded pubs at
all we're not ruling anything out but
we're not saying crowded pubs we're
saying nightclubs and also largest
larger ticketed events
uh as well that's that's that's what
we're looking for some pubs can be as
busy as a nightclub
i think this is the difficulty to be
fair and we've got to work on the
definition we've got to define it really
um carefully and then we'll do that
that's why i'm asking the coming months
until we get there for that rick for
that reason because what we what we're
after what we're after is we're trying
to make sure that
i mean even nightclubs the very
different types of venues you get some
big warehouse
type venues and you get some very small
rooms with
a lack of ventilation because it's all
about ventilation and that's that's what
we're
working on but we'll work on that over
the over the next few weeks alongside
nightclub operators i was speaking to
some last week and i know they're
disappointed this morning
clearly because they want us they will
be open last night they
they want to be able to open and be able
to return to profit
uh because they've been so hard-pressed
but this is the right thing to do
to make sure that we can really get on
top of the transmission of cases
so um sporting venues
uh well there are a number of sporting
venues that are already
looking at voluntarily doing this so
you'll you'll see this
coming into place well before september
it's really i'm sorry to interrupt you
but it's
really important it's really important
for my viewers this morning to know what
they can and can't do
you are representing the government this
morning and you as
a representative of the government are
telling us uh that we have to
have a vaccine passport from september
but you can't tell me where
for now what i'm saying what i'm saying
to you
is that we are looking at having
nightclubs and other uh
large uh ticketed events when people are
coming together
this will be in september so we'll work
on the details over the uh
over the next few weeks it's got to go
through parliamentary scrutiny so we've
got to get it absolutely right we've got
to work with the sectors that are going
to be affected
to make sure that we can define this
really carefully all we're doing now is
giving an advanced warning of what is
coming down the line
to make sure that the nhs doesn't get a
swamp denote overbought
with with with cases over the winter but
we'll work on that detail with the
sector we'll give you plenty of notice
well they're seen as super spreader
events that according to patrick valance
if they're seen as super spread or
events like night clubs why are you
waiting till september
because we've got to get the detail
right and what we're trying to do is get
people vaccinated now we're trying to
encourage people as i say
85 percent of adults have had their
first dose 65
have had their both doses we're
encouraging people to get uh
to to to get vaccinated but it's right
that we actually
um stop mandating as much stuff as we
can from the government
and let the economy start to bounce back
but clearly there's still going to be
challenges you don't
this isn't a film that you kill the
baddie you get to the you know the end
of all credits we're still living with
it so if you could pressure that we've
got a lot to get through this morning
a lot to get through so basically what
you're saying is that you're using it as
a bribe to get young kids
to go and get vaccinated ahead of
september
no no no what we're saying is that we we
want to keep people safe we want to stop
the nhs
being overwhelmed by cases throughout
the winter we know that winters
um has particular pressures and so
that's the fate that what we have to
face
we're still living with covid okay are
you completely comfortable
as a member of the conservative party of
having what amounts to
an id card by another name
no i'm not comfortable that the
government is mandating anything
uh frankly you know i'm a very
libertarian
conservative i want to be able to back
off and that's why yesterday was an
opportunity for government to back off
from so many different things
and let people live their lives but what
we have to do is make sure that people
can also live their lives
safely the nhs can function safely and
these are the challenges that we still
have to do so
it's incredibly frustrating it's
incredibly complicated to work through
the detail
but that's the challenge we have don't
understand why you're not introducing it
straight away then if it's not a bribe
forget for young people to uh get
vaccinated why are you waiting
until september i don't get it
because we we we need to look at um as i
say the detail behind it as well to make
sure that um
nightclub operators and other event
operators actually work at work work
can know how to operationalize the
detail to be able to
work it through on the door we've got to
get the technology right as well and
we've got to
we've got to make sure people can you
know fully understand what's coming but
in the meantime we're
encouraging people to use it and
operators to use it voluntarily and i
hope that
some night club operators and event
operators will be using it
voluntarily to keep people safe within
their venues you've had 18 months these
nightclubs have been
shot for 18 months why didn't you do it
before now
18 months ago we uh that we didn't even
know what we're facing so i'm not sure
we've had 18 months to do it because
we've only just
really worked through this spread or the
air assaults that were there
what we've been encouraging nightclubs
to do is and i know loads of nightclub
operators already do this
is make sure that they're increasing
their um air changes in their venues
because it's so much of it it's about
ventilation
and as i said you've got a lot of
different types of operators a lot of
different types of venues
so when you're trying to bring something
in that can actually work with
hospitality venues across the board then
it's it it is difficult and it is
frustrating around the edges for
something
operated okay so there's lots more to
talk about with that in the coming days
and weeks
um talk to me about the i think we've
got an image of the
front cover of your manifesto the tory
manifesto for the last election
the first page saying that there'll be
no rise in national insurance
and there it is circled for you right
there no rise in national
insurance that was a pledge from boris
johnson he signed it at the bottom
um are you increasing national insurance
well i i've read about the speculation
this morning that's not something i
recognize so
you know we'll see what happens in terms
of the uh
when we announce our details on social
care but which is what i think you're
talking about but uh that's not
something i recognize
so how would you feel given that it was
a pledge from the prime minister
if there was an increase in national
insurance how should my viewers feel
this morning about that
well what what i think your viewers will
want is a solution for social care and i
think that's why
they'll want you to take them too they
elected you on your manifesto
and you're going back on your manifesto
pledge if you put up national insurance
so what i'm saying is
how do you feel that they should feel
about that if you did
once we found okay i'm not going to get
involved in speculation on a newspaper
report it's not something i recognize
but what we do want it to happen
is to make sure that we can come up with
a comprehensive approach um program to
tackle social care it's been around
for a long time this issue we really do
need to get to grips with it
and that's what the prime minister and
the health secretary are really
determined to do
okay what's this that i'm reading about
your boss saying he didn't believe the
nhs would
be overwhelmed during the pandemic
last year if you did say that and if you
did think that
why did you spend half a billion pounds
on nightingale hospitals
i'm assuming you're talking about the
interviews with dominic cummings which
is some something that will
come out later i mean look we we were in
this situation over the last 18 months
when we've been
uh living with covert we've been
learning about kobe as has happened over
the global pandemic
there are plenty of things that we've
done uh to
to prepare some of which we needed uh to
the nth degree some of which we didn't
need as much the nightingale hospitals
were absolutely played a pivotal role if
you speak to anybody
that was working in those nightingale
hospitals the stuff that they saw the
stuff they had to deal with was
was horrific um and uh and so
it was right that we actually set up a
lot to tackle something we really didn't
know what we were facing
um the one in london was hardly used
but nonetheless the the people that were
there were actually as i say pretty um
uh in horrendous condition and so you
know i haven't spoken to the the guy in
my local hospital that helped set it up
um you know firsthand experience of a
first-hand story of the sort of
what he had to face and it it it wasn't
pretty and
that wasn't a nightingale hospital
though was it no that wasn't a
nightingale hospital that you're talking
about there was it
yes it was no it was it was the
nightingale it was the original
nightingale hospital and the excel
center so
okay so it was worth the half a billion
pounds that was spent on the nightingale
hospitals despite your boss saying
that the nhs would not be overwhelmed
we've
we've we've we've spent 407 billion
pounds
trying to get the economy safe trying to
save people's lives trying to make sure
that we could
uh keep the pressure as best we could
off the nhs
some of which were we could have needed
more some of which we
you know we may well have overspent
because we could in terms of the fact
that uh
we didn't know what we were facing it
was right that we keep people safe
that's the
that's the first rule of any government
keep
keep people safe and that's what we've
been trying to do that's what we'll
continue to do
okay um is spain going to be added to
the amber watch list
those sort of decisions are taken um at
cabinet level they'll
they'll look at the data and they'll
make sure that they can uh
work out what it what is best to make
sure that uh
we keep transmission of the virus low we
keep the transmission of the variance
low
because it's the variants that are
really key here to work out how they how
they're
interacting with our with our vaccine
program a lot of people
who've gone on holiday to spain will be
watching us uh this morning in their
hotel rooms before they go out for the
day
he's talking about the data um the
numbers
uh in mainland uh france
were three times lower than what they
are
in spain at the moment so does that mean
that you're going to put them on the
list
or or not i mean they'll want to know
whether they need to book a flight
look it's not just about we try and give
people as much notice as we can okay but
it's not just about the pure numbers
it's also about the
the variance and the style of variance
the beta variant for example that's um
that's uh
quite prevalent in france at the moment
uh we're looking about how that
interacts
with the astrazeneca vaccine and so
there's a lot of factors that involved
in in the decisions that are taken
around travel
comes back to the point i was saying
earlier we've got to keep people safe
and we've got to make sure that we can
keep on top of carrying on with travel
carrying on with travel
um the us has put us the uk on the
highest
risk level do you think that's fair
well again they would take their
decisions i'm not going to comment on
their decisions i think what you know
what we've got to do is look at
um and have discussions with with with
the us and other countries to make sure
that we can
keep as much open as possible because
we've talked a lot about the uk
but you're right to look at travel not
just for holidays although it's
hugely important this time of year but
to make sure that we can remain
connected
that's good for the economy it's good
for actually getting that money in
through the treasury to cover the costs
of the things that we've just been
talking about
okay a final thought before i let you go
cinderella um
has been um canned at least for now when
will lord lloyd webber be able to open
his new production
well there's some productions that are
opening this week i know that but i know
how frustrating it is because with
people getting pinged and this is
why we're trying to work through this
we're trying to uh to to make sure that
we can
keep people safe but also uh make sure
people can get back to work i know
really how frustrating it is because i'm
the minister for london as well and i
want to see london
back as a vibrant uh community a vibrant
global city
okay did you wear your mask at the
evening standard party last night
i wore my mask going in and out but uh
but but not in the party itself
okay thanks for joining us appreciate it
cheers gate thank you uh talking about
travel weren't we there i'm sorry i
couldn't get any uh clearer guidance for
you on what's happening this is what we
know
uh so far
here we go u.s citizens have been warned
against traveling to the uk
amid the rising number of covert cases
the center
for disease control and prevention has
placed the uk on a level
four very high warning which states even
full vaccinated travelers could be
at risk meanwhile there are reports that
spain could be about to follow france
onto the uk so-called amber plus list
talked about that as well didn't we due
to concerns
over the beta very which is the south
africa variant of the virus
first uh observed as i said in south
africa looks lovely doesn't it
who wants to go there me um still to
come on the programme
for you this morning a warning the
return of empty supermarket shells could
be on the cards due to a shortage of htv
drivers we'll have more on that with
one trade association at the quarter to
eight
we'll hear more about the petition to
give nhs workers a 15
pay rise that's gained 800 000
signatures and later in the program i'm
going to be joined by the paralympic
world
champion left speechless after being
told her sprint briefs
were too brief olivia breen will tell us
more
at a quarter to nine
and i also want to tell you about a
premier league footballer
who's been arrested on suspicion of
child
sex offenses the 31 year old man was
arrested on friday and has been bailed
while police continue to investigate
the player's team has confirmed he has
been suspended
indefinitely pending the police
investigation
the delayed tokyo 2020 olympic games is
nearly upon us with the opening ceremony
set to take place on friday
against the backdrop of the pandemic
joining us now from tokyo is our sports
correspondent tom palmenta standing by
as you can see tom good morning
to you so uh everything should go ahead
as planned on friday although the
covid's pings left right and center
aren't there where you are
yeah this is not gonna be plain sailing
at all it's another very hot day in
tokyo hotter even than the uk
and the athletes that are here in
training camps getting ready for those
games getting ready for their moment the
moment of their lives in many cases
they're just trying to acclimatize to
the heat and work out how much they can
do how far they can push themselves to
get themselves ready
that's one of the things that they can
control of course what they can't
necessarily control
are all those pings of people being told
they're close contacts of people who
have tested positive or
indeed people or athletes we have had a
few of those who have now tested
positive some of them
inside the athletes village itself so
that is
going to disrupt the games there's no
two ways about it south africa
have two of their footballers having
tested positive their first game is a
day or two away and they
are looking at how they get a team out
given that 18
close contacts of those that tested
positive also have to isolate also have
to go through the
extra testing and this will be a theme
throughout the games you'll remember
that team gb have had a
delegation within their track and field
team who are on a plane with someone who
tested positive
they're having to isolate and have extra
support and testing around them
and this is going to go on and on up to
70 now people
who are participants in the games in
some way not spectators of course
because there won't be any
but participants in the games who are
here to cover it or participate
70 now cases and the olympic committee
watching that very closely as we are now
just days away from the opening ceremony
some of the sports are going to start a
little bit earlier softball
is one of them they'll be starting
tomorrow but it is a games on a knife
edge and it could go either way
okay for now thanks very much oh just
before i let you go tom
you're going to be there throughout the
olympics aren't you going to update us
every day
we are we're gonna have some really
special moments and the time zones
actually work really well for breakfast
television so we'll be bringing you some
brilliant british success stories gold
medals are plenty watch out for the
boxing team the taekwondo team they are
looking very very focused indeed
and determined after the year delay that
they've had to get to this olympics
that they're going to make it count k
and apparently a fun fact tom more
female athletes than male athletes in
the gb team this
year
yeah 200 women 175 men
and of course there are some really
established household names laura kenny
in the track cycling
charlotte du jardin in the equestrian
who are going for their third gold
medals in a row
and some really established olympians
but some exciting news stories as well
we've got some brilliant stories to tell
you over the next couple of weeks from
japan please uh
enjoy them on tv and also online for us
we've got some really interesting
uplifting inspirational stuff that
hopefully will give everyone a bit of a
lift
i love the olympics i can't wait thanks
very much tom thank you
yay so all the way through the olympic
games
every morning here on breakfast on the
sky you'll be able to catch up with what
has been happening hopefully all those
amazing gb olympic successes as well as
tom was saying
time now for a look at the morning's
other main stories
and a group of nhs staff campaigners and
mps will deliver a petition
for a 15 pay rise to downing street
later on today
the petition which now has 800 000
signatures
comes as the government is set to
release its long-awaited report
into nhs pay israel's foreign minister
has
accused the ice cream brand ben and
jerry's of capitulating to anti-semitism
after it announced it would stop selling
its products in the occupied palestinian
territories
ben jerry's said operating in west bank
settlements and east jerusalem was
inconsistent with our values following a
boycott by palestinian activists they
decided to give away ice cream
suicide bomber has killed at least 35
people and wounded more than 60 in the
iraqi capital
the attack took place at a market in
saudi city district
of baghdad on the eve of eid
the islamic state group has claimed
responsibility
now there's a new challenge to stop
rentable e-scooter trials with
campaigners claiming the vehicles have
made towns and cities
no-go zones for blind people shingi
marariki reports
blind in one eye and partially sighted
in the other tom walker's trip
into liverpool city center can be hard
enough
in recent weeks that journey has been
made even more difficult
the new obstacle e-scooters a few
saturdays ago fairly near where we're
standing at liverpool central train
station
i was walking out and the first thing i
knew was kind of like a whoosh of air
went past me and i'm like
oh my goodness what was that and a lady
a couple of meters away said
you've just nearly been run over by an
e-scooter
following a government decision to
legalize rental trials last month
signing up to use one of these vehicles
can be done in minutes after some safety
checks
campaigners are worried about their
safety though they want to put the
brakes on for hire schemes
stop the sale of private scooters and
prevent their use on the highways
they say setting off on journeys like
this should not be allowed
a message they will deliver directly to
the prime minister today
in the form of a petition they literally
take over the pavements they're whizzing
in and out of people
at great speeds you know and our members
can't see them
you know they can't hear them there's
talk about putting a sound on them but
to be honest
you're never ever going to get these
riders off the pavement
the police are also preoccupied by
e-scooters
with officers in the west midlands
launching a crackdown on privately owned
ones which are still
illegal any scooter that can be stopped
safely
that is publicly owned is subject to
seizure
and the riders may be reported their
e-scooter is seized
and there's very little hope of them
getting it back
the department for transport says safety
is its top priority
with the trials meant to help them
understand the impact of these in the
public space
with the pilot set to continue until
next year the wheels on this debate
look set to keep on turning shingi
marike
sky news prince harry has announced
he'll be releasing a new
memoir forgive me next year apparently
he's already written the first draft
the duke of sussex has promised to write
an accurate
and wholly truthful account of his life
reflecting on both the highs
and the lows it'll be the first time as
senior royal has ever shared such a
personal account of their life
on the page the book's publishers
penguin random house
says we can expect to see it on our
shelves
towards the end of 2022 next year with
the proceeds
all going to charity now the met office
has issued its first ever extreme heat
warning as the uk braces itself to face
more
sweltering conditions in parts of the
country south wales
west midlands south west england and
parts of hampshire
are covered by the warning which will
stay in place until one minute to
midnight on thursday night
the good news for some is that
temperatures are expected to drop
by friday but don't take it from me
take it from huh here she is hi naz good
morning i was just rehearsing for you
but i think you're going to do it much
better than me
what's your fault um
that is exactly right actually it is
looking
very hot for today once again many parts
of northern ireland
england wales are now in a heatwave that
heat
is also going to be transferring its way
slowly northwards
to some parts of south west scotland
where temperatures will be very
unusually high
for the time of year there
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so hot dry and sunny for
the vast majority of the uk
and ireland once again for today the
heat continues the met office
have issued their first ever extreme
heat
warning it's an amber warning to be
prepared for these regions
london southeast england south west
england wales the west midlands
and across these parts there will be
very high temperatures for the time of
year
the combination of the high heat during
the day very warm nights as well could
pose some problems for people's health
infrastructure and travel and it's valid
until the end of thursday so it's a very
warm start already this morning
muggy in places rather murky and cool
though across the north and east of the
uk and around some western coast of
ireland and the north coast of northern
ireland
but there will be plenty of sunshine
developing this afternoon it will be a
very warm or hot day particularly across
central and southwestern
areas where the highest temperatures are
likely but everywhere generally seeing
temperatures above average
the north and east staying quite cool
and cloudy and drizzly and
mainly dry but some heavy showers or
thunderstorms may develop much like
yesterday across parts of ireland
northern ireland central and
southeastern england but they will be
very isolated
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we were mentioning yesterday and want to
underline it again for you
this morning several people have died uh
cooling off
in open water you don't know what is
underneath
the surface do bear that in mind won't
you so
several people as i said have died over
the last couple of days trying to cool
off
in those incredibly hot temperatures be
very aware before you get into the water
even if it looks as though it's fine you
don't know what's underneath so please
please please
bear that in mind um tamara's here here
tomorrow um the minister chatting to us
a bit a little while ago i'm not clear
what the definition is of when you're
going to need a vaccine passport he
didn't want to give any detail on that
when he put
him pubs workplaces all he said was
we rule nothing out the only plans at
the moment are for nightclubs
at the end of september but boris
johnson yesterday referred to other
venues where large crowds gather he
talked about ticketed
event sounds a bit like uh it stands at
wembley perhaps although that
is outside so why do we have no detail
because the government know they're
going to get a backlash over this there
are going to be a lot of tory mps
who see this as id cards by the back
door i won't want to vote for it we've
already
seen some of them saying we want to see
the evidence if labour don't support it
they'll have a real battle getting it
through the house of commons so i expect
we're not going to see any more detail
until just before the votes in september
in the meantime the government
desperately hoping that venues just
bring in
kobe passports voluntarily and that
takes the sting out of it
and waiting until september although the
virus is rampant now he also said no no
no it's not a bribe for young people to
get a jab
that's right patrick valance chief
scientific officer said that nightclubs
are super spread at events
we've got potentially another two months
of them before this policy is brought in
i think the government are very much
hoping that venues which appeal to
younger people
will bring this passport in of their own
accord but these venues are saying look
it's going to be a bit of a job for us
to enforce it especially if they're
smaller venues where they have to take
on extra
door staff these are the sort of
calculations that
are going to be difficult for
hospitality venues probably some of the
bigger ones will do it and others
won't we've got three million under 30s
who've not had their first
jab yet the vaccination rates are quite
low at the moment only 18
000 yesterday will this policy
convince people to have it or will
forcing them to do it make people recoil
from it
the government simply don't know okay
actually we've
why don't we actually listen to the
exchange that i had
with the minister um a little bit
earlier on i was asking him
uh why they were only going to come into
force in september with clubs having
been open
for the last two nights here's our
exchange
now i'm not comfortable that the
government is mandating anything
uh frankly you know i'm a very
libertarian
conservative i want to be able to back
off and that's why yesterday was an
opportunity for government to back off
from so many different things
and let people live their lives but what
we have to do is make sure that people
can also live their lives
safely the nhs can function safely and
these are the challenges that we still
have to do so
it's incredibly frustrating it's
incredibly complicated to work through
the detail
but that's the challenge we have don't
understand why you're not introducing it
straight away then if it's not a bribe
forget for young people to get
vaccinated why are you waiting
until september i don't get it
because we we we need to look at um as i
say the detail behind it as well to make
sure that um
nightclub operators and other event
operators actually work it work work
it can know how to operationalize the
detail
to be able to work it through on the
door we've got to get the technology
right as well
and we've got to we've got to make sure
people can you know fully understand
what's coming but in the meantime we're
encouraging people to use it and
operators to use it voluntarily
and i hope that some night club
operators and event operators will be
using it
voluntarily to keep people safe within
their venues
so until until last week ministers had
for months been adamant we weren't going
to have
vaccine passports now they think it
might be the answer
but really how much of it mps and venues
are going to
be able to actually enforce will be the
key test there okay tomorrow for now
thank you
well as the country opens up the
government is gambling that the defense
of the vaccine will prevent hospitals
being
overwhelmed so is the vaccination
rollout winning the race
against the virus here's our data editor
ed conway
the uk has one of the highest levels of
vaccination per capita
in the world you can see it on this
chart just look at these lines the
higher they are the more people are
double vaccinated and let the uk up
there
uh not as high as israel but certainly
higher than many other countries uh
around the world the us germany uh and
others as well
which begs the question why are we also
at the same time seeing this line going
higher this shows you cases
per capita and look at the uk line
higher than anyone else basically
cases are rising very fast does that
mean the vaccinations aren't working
well it comes down to the fact that
vaccines potentially do two things
they're supposed to do two things first
of all potentially protect you from
infection
secondly protect you from severe
infections so protect you from having to
go
to a hospital those are two different
things and it's worth just underlining
that there are different effects with
these vaccines so for instance at the
moment with that alpha variant the
higher these bonds are the more they're
protecting you
against infections so 89 protection
against actually getting the disease or
passing it on
with the alpha variant with the delta
variant look 35
if you've had one jab uh 79 if you've
had two jabs so
you're not fully protected there's still
a pretty significant chance
uh one in five that you might actually
get the disease how about against
hospitalization so that other strand the
other thing that vaccines are supposed
to do well here
the news is much better 93 protection
for double jab people
uh against hospitalization with alpha
that's the old kent variant and with the
delta variant that new indian variant
you're talking about 96
uh protection against hospitalization
compared with people who
are unjabs and just to underline what
we're talking about here that still
means
look 21 chance of infection even if
you're double jabbed versus not being
double jabbed
but a four percent chance of
hospitalization so hospitalization lower
uh but when it comes to infection
chances are still relatively
high you're certainly protected but
there's still a chance and that's why
we're seeing this that
line of cases going up and up and up you
can see that winter spike
earlier but you can see cases going
higher with a lot of people who are
double jab getting covered 19
but hospitalizations i put it on a
different axis but you can see the shape
is correlated there across the winter
but just look at the moment case is
going up but emissions they've diverging
those two lines so emissions not going
up half
as fast still going up but not as fast
and not getting to the same kind of
levels
and when you look around the uk you
certainly see hot spots where there's
lots
of covered 19. so redcar and cleveland
you're talking about 1563 cases
per hundred thousand that's the highest
level in the uk and then also
in that area so middlesbrough 1404 cases
and if we look around that south tees
uh area at those case levels so same
thing again you can see the winter spike
and now you can see look case is higher
than they were in the winter spike an
extraordinary rise in the number of
covert cases but look at
hospitalizations
so they've gone up they've certainly
gone up correlated in winter
but right now although they're rising
they're nowhere near as
high as they were in the winter whereas
cases are higher than they've ever been
before so that's encouraging as is the
fact that there are some areas in the uk
where you have lower levels considerably
lower levels
of covered 19 so the orkney islands
you've got 49 cases per hundred thousand
but worth
saying as lockdown ends those numbers
are expected to rise
he's so clever isn't he now the health
secretary sergey javid has announced
that children deemed to be at an
increased risk of getting serious covet
19
and to be offered this fisa vaccine as
soon as possible
it follows advice from the joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization but the body has
for now ruled out the mass vaccination
for under 18s
joining us now is adam finn he's a
professor of pediatrics at the
university of bristol
and a member of the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization hello
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning professor
um we're seeing countries like the us
and france and israel starting to
vaccinate uh
children on mass um why aren't we doing
it in the uk do you think
well at this point in time for the uk
it's not clear that the risk benefit
balance is in favor of immunizing all
healthy 12 year olds
we've got very good data from the first
and second waves
and the risks to children of that age of
hospitalization and death
are actually vanishingly low
so in that context we need to be
absolutely sure that the risks of
receiving the vaccine
are not greater than the risks
posed by the infection to children um
and at this point in time we're not sure
about that so we need to have more
evidence before we can be confident
that it will be in their favor to
receive the vaccine
yeah it'd be like wearing masks though
for adults isn't it the thing about kids
is
you know they bounce back very quickly
but they're pesky little super spreaders
aren't they and
if we vaccinate all of them then less
likely to give it to granny
uh well two points to make about that
first of all actually in contrast to
other viruses where children really are
super spreaders
uh not only do they get less ill but
they are less infectious than adults
uh with kogit but the other thing is
that while it's really important that we
do try
to protect the population we do need to
be sure
that the people actually being given the
vaccines are also benefiting
we can't really be immunising children
just for the benefit of adults if it's
not benefiting the children
themselves so so that's what we need to
be certain about before we move forward
with this or
any other vaccine in this age group you
say less infectious i mean we're waiting
for the figures the figures will come
out for the number of kids that are not
at school because um they've been pinged
or the equivalent
um and that could be i don't know maybe
a million um uh
tamara's not here so i can't get the
exact figure from her but
um you know you're saying they're not
infectious so why are they all off
school
uh well certainly uh maybe i misspoke
the
the children are going to be able to
infect each other that's just that
they're less infectious to each other
than
than adults are so of course
they can get the infection and they can
infect each other
but what we see with other viruses is
that there are big outbreaks in schools
which
really drive the infection into the
population that
that happens with influenza for example
whereas in
schools in the uk so far the rates of
infection have tended to reflect
the broader rates of infection in the
community around them
in the way that you were just showing on
the map just now so
of course children can infect each other
but they're just not that infectious
um dame sarah gilbert you know um she's
amazing isn't she
for people who don't know i'm sure most
of my viewers do know this morning she's
the leader of the team that developed
the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine we saw at
wimbledon
getting her a stunning ovation which was
lovely to see
she thinks rather than jabbing teenagers
what we should be doing
is uh sending these doses that we're
using to
other parts of the world uh where they
would benefit from it
more like south africa for example only
two percent of the population having
been vaccinated there
as we speak
uh well sarah is absolutely right uh
from the global perspective
not only is it would it be fairer and
more equitable
to immunize use the vaccine doses we've
got to immunize the people who are most
likely to die from covid
but it would actually benefit us as well
in the sense that
it would reduce the risk of importing
further
variants of the virus in the future that
might develop elsewhere
of course that kind of international
consideration is
well outside the remit of jcvi which is
tasked with
considering what we should be doing in
the uk but on a personal basis i
entirely sympathize with
that view and uh indeed for the work
that i do for the who we're
pressing very hard that countries should
share out vaccine
more equitably and try and bring the
global pandemic under control
as soon as possible um professor you're
in france uh this morning i can see
um is it right that uh that france is on
the amber plus list
uh do you mean in terms of the
quarantine rules and so on
yeah yeah so the
i think that decision has been taken
because of concerns around the beta
variant
although i'm not uh completely familiar
with the figures
uh so i i yeah i'm not really sure quite
what the thinking was behind that
uh clearly there's a lot of uncertainty
in the whole
business of travel at the moment and and
people
have been burned several times now by
changes in the rules
uh so yes uncertain times when it comes
to travel
yeah even stay where you are for now is
my advice to you professor thanks very
much indeed for joining us as always
appreciate it
thanks a lot nice talking to you thank
you you too now there are countries
across the world where the vaccine is
already being rolled out to those under
the age of 18. among them
is israel where children above the age
of 12
can receive a jab let's talk about it
in more detail joining us from jerusalem
is professor erin siegel a scientist
at the weizmann institute of science
hello to you thank you for
joining us on the programme um which
groups
of young people are being jabbed in
israel at the moment what age groups
so at this stage everybody above the age
of 12
can receive a vaccine and actually is
encouraged to get a vaccine at this
point
with uh the uh re outbreak that we are
seeing now with the delta variant
and why has israel made that decision
because we heard
i don't know if you heard from our
professor that we were chatting to a few
moments ago
and he said he was telling us that isn't
necessarily the case and
that isn't why we're not doing it in the
uk for now
uh so so i think uh there are multiple
reasons uh some of which
may be a little bit unique to israel the
primary one is that israel is a
relatively very young country we have
about 30 percent of the population is
below
the age of 16 so it's a significant it's
a significant number
and that can have multiple effects first
on the children themselves
as we are learning uh more and more
about the
long-term effects of kovid we understand
that there are
uh long-term effects and uh this is a
disease that we really would not want
the children uh to uh to receive uh and
at the same time we understand that the
disease that the
vaccines are very safe even for the
children and on top of that
uh at this stage of the pandemic this is
going to
help us tremendously in trying to bend
the curve and lower
infections overall because we know as i
just saw in your report
that the vaccines are also quite
effective not 100 but quite effective
in reducing infections and therefore the
children
if they receive the vaccines that will
help contain
the pandemic in israel as well but
nevertheless am i right in saying that
cases are starting to rise in israel
yes absolutely we are now in uh what we
are calling here our
uh fourth wave um i think there's a lot
of uncertainty but
the government has made uh a brave and
in my view a correct decision to
dramatically shift the way it's managing
the pandemic
whereas instead of looking at just the
cases now the
primary uh parameter that we are looking
at is the number of critically
or severely ill patients at the hospital
that number
remains low at the moment which is why
the regular routine life
uh is uh at the moment continuing um
and we are often seeing encouraging
results in israel similar to what you
just showed where
the conversion rate from cases to
hospitalizations and
also to mortality has dropped
by a lot in israel we have seen roughly
a three-fold
drop i think you were seeing similar
numbers in the uk
and the meaning of that is that in order
for us to go back to
the very high levels of hospitalizations
that we saw here
in the third wave that would probably
require three times more cases per day
than we saw at our peak
we hope to not reach that stage at all
but if we do reach that stage
then what will happen is that at that
stage we will accumulate
many people who are going to be
recovered those recovered people are
going to
uh are going to or will not be infected
and and that will help us to reach back
the herd immunity that we were at before
uh the delta variant so we believe that
there is a
um good possibility that in several
weeks we will start to see the bed the
curve
bending as may also be the case in the
uk
as both israel and the uk have very very
high rates
of their population uh protected either
through vaccination
or because some of the population has
been
infected and recovered okay it's good to
talk to you thanks for that explanation
appreciate it thank you
thank you and good morning thank you in
israel they are vaccinating
all of their kids here in the uk we are
only vaccinating children or
for now only vaccinated children who are
uh clinically
vulnerable and that was the explanation
from both sides as to why that is
now there's been a record migrant
crossing across the english
channel and uh for the latest on this is
our correspondent
hurinag and she's standing by for us as
you can see hi ashna good morning tell
us more
good morning to you yeah with the
weather as it is it's almost something
we've come to expect
really with the summer season brings
more migrants more suspected migrants
willing to make that crossing and take
that risk over that 20-mile
uh dover strait we know that there has
been a record total last september 416
people making that crossing
yesterday the home office told us that
number reached 430 many people crossing
and arriving onto a beach not far from
here in dover
arriving men women children looking
incredibly relieved
exhausted but also some of them very
celebratory these numbers
come at a very timely time in parliament
the home secretary priti patel
said last year that she was willing to
try and make this route across the
channel unviable they are currently
debating
a nationality and borders bill in
parliament which would include things
like perhaps
uh processing migrants in offshore
countries a bit like australia does but
until the weather remains as it does
right now
many people continuing to take that risk
okay for now thanks a lot thank you
remember the early days of the pandemic
when an influx in panic buying led us
to see empty shells in our supermarkets
toilet rolls what was that about
well food supplies are now warning that
a shortage of
hgv drivers could mean problems once
again
for supply chains here to tell us more
is uh tony good shirt from the
association of
independent meat supplies hello t thanks
for joining us
on the program this morning what's the
problem
well firstly we don't have sufficient
htv drivers in
this country now many of them were
migrant workers who came to the country
now can i just stop you there if i may
just for a second because your
microphone is just catching on your
shirt and so we can't there we go
there we go i'll hold it thank you sorry
the main problem is that we're very
short of hgv drivers it's estimated
about 70 000 shorts at the moment many
of the htv
drivers were in the uk
came from the european union and of
course they've returned home
one of the big problems is that the home
office isn't seeing
hgv drivers as being a skilled job we
have a letter from the home office which
says the job of an htv driver does not
meet the threshold
so it's not eligible to be added to the
shortage occupation list
to be sponsored for a skilled worker
visa now
obviously that means that we don't have
those drivers now here in the country
and what drivers we do have
some of them are being pinged and
obviously can't go to work
uh others have chosen to go and work
perhaps not necessarily as hgv drivers
but as
uh small parcel van drivers as the
explosion home shopping has started
uh what what issues have you seen
because you've not had enough staff
um well i represent the meat and poultry
industry and what we're seeing
with our members is uh firstly a bit of
a struggle in actually getting
livestock into processing it's important
to remember that
although the home office describe an hgv
driver is not being skilled
a livestock driver an hgv livestock
driver
is also trained in animal welfare and
animal transportation so they have those
additional skills
so without sufficient drivers what we're
getting is
stock backing up on farm and when stock
backs up on farm
there is uh you know the potential for
um
animal welfare issues to take place on
farm which obviously nobody wants to see
so we need to be having drivers who can
move stock from
farm to processor and we also need hgv
drivers to move
product from processor into the
just-in-time supply chain
in terms of our members sorry no i was
just going to ask you if i may because
we've not got a lot of time left but i
just wanted to ask you about the
transport secretary uh granting an
extension to working hours for hdv
drivers i believe is that a good idea
well he's only granted an extra one hour
per day now given that we're coming into
the summer period
the roads are going to be busy with
people staycationing what we could find
is that whole hour is taken up with
fallow time
with the lorries just simply standing
still in traffic jams
so yes we welcome that
but i think we need to be doing much
more to encourage
hgv drivers and training in hev driving
into the uk i would like personally
aims the association of independent
media suppliers would like to see a
coveted recovery passport
uh sorry a covered recovery visa being
introduced for a couple of years
to enable us to get the country back on
its feet
get food production back working it's
all very well
if we can sort out more hgv drivers the
problem we also have is not having
enough food processing staff to put the
food in the lorries to take to the
supermarket
what a mess what an absolute mess thanks
for taking the time to explain it to us
thank you
you're welcome thank you uh let me tell
you that russia
has announced the successful test launch
of a new hypersonic
missile vladimir putin has previously
spoken
about the weapon as part of a new
generation of missiles there it goes
he says they can fly at nine times the
speed of sound which is very fast
and can hit almost any point in the
world and can
even invade a u.s missile shield
the missile was launched in the white
sea and hit a target
more than 217 miles away not that one
time for a quick look at the weather now
uh here's
here she is hi nas good morning
another hot one today kay another hot
day
and another very warm night to come
extreme heat warning from the met office
as well for central and southwestern
areas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning another very warm or hot
day for the vast majority of the uk
and ireland today many parts of northern
ireland wales and england are now
in a heatwave and the office have
now issued their first ever extreme heat
warning it's an amber be prepared
warning for central and southwestern
parts of
england and wales valid until the end of
thursdays these areas
are likely to be hot by day very warm by
night and that combination could cause
some problems for people's health
infrastructure
and travel as well so very bright warm
muggy morning for many areas but across
northern and eastern parts of patches of
mist fog
low cloud it's slightly cooler across
areas of the north and east as well as
around northern and western parts of
ireland and northern ireland but most of
that burns away back towards coastal
areas
so it is going to be another sunny very
warm or hot day for the vast majority
particularly across central and southern
areas
and further north not as warm for
northern and eastern scotland the far
northeast finger where it stays quite
murky and cool perhaps for the north
coast of northern ireland too
mainly dry but some heavy showers
possible for the central and
southeastern areas and possibly for
ireland and northern ireland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways